sí sin duda está en juego el futuro
político de boris johnson sí sí el
partido de conservador así lo quiere
boris johnson sería removido de su cargo
como líder del partido conservador y
entonces primer ministro pero para eso
se necesitan 54 cartas de diputados
conservadores que digan que han perdido
la confianza en su líder entonces se
activaría una moción de censura de
confianza no hay certeza de cuántas
cartas hasta este momento ha recibido el
comité 1922 que se encarga de estos
asuntos dentro del partido conservador
sin embargo aunque sí es cierto este
reporte de su grey como lo mencionaba
divulgado en su totalidad hoy es
escandaloso y deja muy mal parado al
primer ministro y a su gobierno este no
tiene ninguna multa económica ni ninguna
sanción disciplinaria entonces no
necesariamente este sería el motivo por
el que boris johnson sería sacado de su
cargo como primer ministro pero
recordemos que el parlamento británico
también iniciará una investigación
contra el primer ministro para si
johnson mintió deliberadamente sobre
estas fiestas en downing street ya que
como sabemos en repetidas oportunidades
negó en la cámara de los comunes haber
asistido a estas fiestas aunque johnson
dejó claro hoy en su comparecencia en el
parlamento que quiere que este sea un
asunto cerrado y del pasado es claro que
un punto final se ve todavía muy lejos